Paul comme tu l'aurais comme tu l'auras
compris on t'a préparé un quiz ah avec
différents niveaux
ah alors est-ce que tu es prêt Paul oui
mais je suis pas sûr que je vais
répondre à tout hein allez Paul commence
par le quel théologien ah c'est un pote
déjà philosophe et évque d'pone ah
Saint-Augustin oh
Saint-Augustin évec d'pone avec dip
c'est extrêmement fort c'est extrêmement
fort bravo
bravo
fils de sainte Monique ah bien bien ah
ou quel roi de France convoqua la
première réunion des États généraux du
royaume de France à NotreDame de Paris
le 10 avril 1302 et ben Ctait au même
moment que l'attentat d'Ani contre
Boniface 8 ah oui exactement et c'est
Philippe
[Applaudissements]
Lebelle qui fut assassiné le 29 décembre